definitely
we've also been following breaking news
developments out of canada at least 10
people have been killed another 15
injured in stabbings this at 13
different locations in saskatchewan
province police say they are looking for
two suspects
let's get more in this now from mike
hannah in washington
have you been hearing much about this
mike
well the story has just been breaking
within the last few minutes in terms of
any further detail very difficult the
police say that they are looking for two
suspects a number of people have been
stabbed at least 15 wounded but the
issue is is that this is over a fairly
wide expanse of area these attacks have
happened over a period of a few hours
now this is in saskatchewan it's ranging
through an area
near port albert now it's also at this
stage there's a football match been
going on in the town of wexton and it
appears that the initial stabbings
happen in this area but have then spread
out across several different districts
over the past few hours the royal
canadian mounted police say that they
are looking for two suspects they've
identified them they've identified the
vehicle that they are traveling in but
at
this time they are still at large uh the
rscpnp don't give any reason for the
stabbing they don't understand any
motive at this particular point but they
are searching for the two people they
believe are responsible as i said at
least 10 people killed at this
particular point according to the rcmp
as many as 15 have been injured in the
series of stabbings which have erupted
within the last few hours in a large
area of saskatchewan in canada all right
thank you very much for that mike hannah
in washington